hello to all of you wonderful viewers of
the not too deep podcast just want to
give you a quick heads-up about this
episode and next week's episode
unfortunately we had a hard drive
failure which happens to the best of us
so in this episode the footage from my
camera angle didn't make it so
unfortunately unfortunately gonna be
subjected to the beautiful faces of
Kimmie Gatewood and Rebecca Johnson the
whole time
but we still want to post the video
because I love these two ladies and it
was a really really wonderful episode
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by Squarespace turn your great
idea into a reality with Squarespace
they make it easier than ever to launch
your passion project whether you're
showcasing your work or selling products
of any kind and with beautiful templates
and the ability to customize just about
anything you can easily make a beautiful
website all on your own
but if you do get stuck Squarespace is
24/7 award-winning customer support is
there to help
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain welcome to another episode of
not too deep with me your host grace
Helbig this is a very exciting episode I
say that every time but this one truly
is guys hear me out
we have Kimmie Gatewood and Rebecca
Johnson if you don't know them they're
the tag team on glow the beatdown
biddies and the toxic twins and this
isn't saying because we go back
literally like 10 years they were both
individually improv teachers of mine in
my past in New York City at the people's
Improv Theater so there's a long history
here and I'm so inspired and excited to
hear everything that they've been up to
with the franchise that is empowering
women across the world glow and all of
the the in-betweens have been going on
they're also moms what then they can do
everything so get ready for this very
fun very sweet they're dumb in a good
way episode of not too deep with Kimmie
Gatewood and Rebecca Johnson
I'm so glad that you guys are here thank
you for making time this is so fun I
have a billion questions because Chlo is
fantastic and you must be so out of it
and so excited to be part of like what
feels like the closest thing I can
relate to is like a sorority I didn't
grow up with Greek life at all when I
went to college yeah neither did we
marching band for three months and then
it quick did you play trombone okay
plays so play yeah I mean yeah I have no
musical talent so envious on every level
there's not a party only way where we
don't regret that she didn't bring her
fully fair I don't think I've ever heard
the origin story of how you two met each
other for the first time and I'm sure
you've told this a billion times yeah I
would love to hear it so we really met
back in the day at UCB but when we
became friends as when we were both
teaching at the pit right and we were
the only gals teaching you know somehow
we busted through that plexiglass
feeling definitely like some kind of
asbestos because we were the only two
females in the faculty show people work
constantly like you guys should do shows
together we were like like at first
being like Joe will perform with the
guys just like everyone else
yeah you're free you're gonna lose your
spot is like that girl you know but then
Kimmy made a comedy pinup calendar mhm
and I saw it and thought it was the
funniest thing I'd ever seen in my whole
life and was like okay yes please let's
do a show together yeah and then we
brought along Sara Lowe who we also were
you know talking to to it as she's in
other gals so we're gonna do a show
separately like two-person show and then
reckons like let's do a show together
yes no I don't have time for that why
don't all three of a sous chef yeah we
talked the phone so I was doing urine
now we're getting to the Apple sisters
not even yeah yeah when we started our
comedy group the Apple sisters what year
was that 2007 well dude open in six when
we talked about it and I first show Alex
Alvin signed us up for February 14 2007
Wow and what was like the initial like
idea of it like how did you guys pitch
it to each other well we were talking
about what I was saying that I thought
we should host a variety show mhm and
kami brought up like MO and Sarah was
talking about like musicals and it's
like we all love musicals and singing
and dancing and then came he brought up
the 1940's because you can sing and
ironically like just burst out into song
for no reason that make sense I thought
you would just like out of nowhere like
I would like to talk about the 1914
mildly obsessed with Judy Garland there
was also there's also this musical 1940s
Radio Hour which is a really funny
musical okay where are you doing a live
radio show and like like I really
enjoyed that and I think slapstick
comedy like you can physical comedy like
it's all like okay and it doesn't seem
hacky or weird it's like if you
encapsulate the 1940s you cannot only
comment on modern society you can
comment on like societal norms yeah we
could sing in three-part harmony and
we're like red let's say actually care
about like looking cute on stage so you
guys are still doing that right yeah we
have a show in a week and like yeah
we're doing shows we have shows in Vegas
shows in LA yeah that's what's gonna ask
because it's you know a period piece
kind of comedy show how does it play in
Vegas like how does it do it's great
love it actually I feel the audience is
even more responsive than in New York
really really yeah because it's you know
it's a period piece but it's so much
through the through the 2018 lens yeah
so it's not like we're like sticking to
this exact you know historical version
of the 40's it's a you know we're in
some ways a parody oh my god no we are I
rewrote um encyclopedias and gave them
to Kimmy and so she thinks it's historic
but it's all my writing it was a lot of
work look like a ransom note I was
cutting out pictures of pages of
magazines too like for the letter I mean
this is why did I do it I always wonder
why I did it
but yeah we you know we started by
thinking we were just gonna do like a
new monthly show and then it became this
thing that we've done since 2007 yeah
basically and we loved it we we do the
dresser last Comedy Festival she doesn't
eat which changed our lives because yeah
we got there yeah we went out there and
we had no representation which we didn't
know at the time then that was the best
way you could possibly go out because
literally agents were following us
around back to New York the roof of like
a Hotel Gansevoort because you guys
killed it just for last
in the like sketch comedy portion
garbage at the time they could get away
with even though it's only ten years ago
but now I don't think you could have
that level I know but I mean that was
that was insane because like literally a
year before I was like eating eggs the
cheapest thing to eat eggs and I'd be
like okay yogurt is a dollar 25 cents we
were like teaching you yeah what fun
days I know I was like literally eating
beans out of a can like it's fiber but
that's so bonkers have you ever had
because it is you get I think it must be
super fun to be able to have this lens
on a show where you get to comment on
like the modern things happening without
getting such blowback of being like your
female comedians talking about politics
right so have you ever had like a
bizarre like crowd moment or someone
come up to you after a show or say
something that's like offended by
something you've done or have you had
the opposite of someone that was like so
over the top like that was incredible
like almost
I feel like the ever someone being
offended is you know the 1940s we're
dealing with like different people we
were at war with so then it's like the
Apple sisters are making jokes and then
like there was like specifically like a
Japanese joke and then my friend brought
her family and she's of Asian descent
and they were offended and it was like
they and it was hard I was like
something I had to look at and be like
yes it is through the 1940s but also no
matter what were three white women
mm-hmm so I think that there's we've
made certain changes even in our show
because it's different every time like
there's scripted stuff but then there's
things that we've made changes as the
time has gone on and certain topics were
much easier to tackle when Obama was
president because life seemed was
president yeah we stand that was a
strange time because like our first joke
was like there's a war going on it's
food food is being rationed you know and
like there was an actual war going on he
talked very presently about the war
right even like about like like candies
characters obviously it in the closet
lesbian we're able to talk about gay
like culture and and like when gay
marriage was finally passed like all of
those things we could talk about it in a
different way rather than marriage
that's a special woman running for
president would be like oh the woman
running for president like we thought
it's kind of crazy that - we changed it
at a certain point like that's the spot
I've had as a woman becoming president
and it's like oh that's an years later
that Joe still plays like I know it
plays in such a different way that you
could have ever expected
yeah oh dang but at least you get to
keep doing it and I feel like that kind
of stuff is ultimately very good
especially in the world in which we live
in now which i think is very cool cuz i
like internet's talk to you guys a bunch
to like try and keep up with everything
that's happening in your worlds right
now and you guys are so wonderfully
prolific on like your
you use your social media to talk about
serious things even though you're
obviously comedians and you know funny
women in general how do you balance like
being comedic and then using or wanting
to talk about certain things online oh I
feel like we've had this rare
opportunity where we're on a pretty high
profile show you kind of it just like
kind of levels you because you want to
make sure that you're responsible with
your voice yeah and you know also
becoming a mother honestly I'm like what
would I want my child to know about me
like what kind of person I am and so I
in fact when globe came along I threw
away my old social media and just
started a new one
I really started without our kids
pictures because I got a couple of
creeps commenting on my baby's picture
and I was like you know what I need to
make sure that like there's like brand
Kimmy gateway and then there's personal
Generation and I know that that's like
I'm not like safety reasons yeah I mean
it only takes one person to make things
weird yeah yes I know especially that
you have kids like I can't fully relate
to that but I understand that that's
probably a very sensitive thing that's
new like you're like oh I didn't even
realize that this kind of world existed
on the right yeah you don't want
anything political you say to then
suddenly somehow the comment goes on
your kids picture like that's just like
yeah yeah so we both kind of like made a
private version just where our kids
pictures get dumped and then our public
you know personas are still us it's just
without the kids stuff and yeah for me
you know I think all the movements that
have happened in Hollywood since I've
been on globe but like even before aglow
with the yesallwomen and all that stuff
and I I had felt strange about just
saying my real experiences so I was sort
of like skate around them and there's
always that balance of like how much
politics do you put on your social media
how many jokes like and it got to the
point where basically this last year
NBC think asked me to write a piece on
feminism or politics yeah and so I was
like well here we go yeah and I decided
to write about like my actual
experiences in like the me to space yeah
and it was so freeing and I was a
to still make it like I still had one or
two jokes in there I when I first wrote
it it was filled with jokes and my
friends who read it were like just be
serious I thought it was really great I
thought you really did a wonderful job
of balancing like the sincerity and the
honesty behind it and keeping it true to
who you are as a human by wanting to
make jokes when it gets uncomfortable or
when you're exposing a lot of yourself
that you haven't before yeah I thought
it was great thank you but I'm sure it
must have been I read your tweet that
was like I just put something seriously
yeah and now I have to restrain myself
from reading comments that is so true
and some of the comments are like not on
that thing but on Twitter we're like Oh
George Soros like paid her to write like
this is like liberal holly was like
really me talking about like my horrible
experiences in high school are you even
paid for but like the liberal elite like
I look what do you talk about but
obviously that didn't affect me as much
as I was more nervous that like people I
knew we're gonna be like oh sure sure
but now I feel more comfortable just now
I can just kind of touch on it any time
yeah use and be comedic about it or not
but it doesn't feel like you're holding
matter and yeah you get liberated in a
sense and you're able to I think talk
about it in a way that helps others
without feeling so like beholdin to this
like secret or something exactly yeah
yeah and I wrote a short film called
consent a short comedy about a serious
subject Kimi directed it we shot at the
summer and so now we're you know
submitting to festivals and so it's all
kind of like coming out of me and that
really was a comedy but I was able to
find a way to talk about this subject
that I really care about really we were
talking about like how do we teach our
kids about consent and I have a son so I
was like how do I make sure he
understands that like more than no means
no but that you have to get the body
language of if someone's not interested
like shut it down we're talking about
like today in the car like for just for
marketing like give somebody a car this
is consent and it's like you can use
this you can give to something you give
someone your consent card if you want
but you could also feel free to take it
back an interesting like physical form
and I
the film touches upon that too it's like
a metaphor an allegory afore like
talking about consent yeah there's no
sex in the film but it's an allegory so
it's like using music instead of sex and
I play the kind of offender and I keep
singing to someone he doesn't want me to
sing to them and so it's really it was
such a awesome experience and so I feel
like just writing an essay telling my
truth and then making a film and kimmy's
been like such a huge part of that and
you know and now I feel like I'm finally
like just starting to use my voice in a
real way that's awesome
art yeah that art healed I have directed
my fair share of one woman shady
characters to okay now I want to talk
about glow speaking of like things that
are impactful and like female
empowerment and all that how did this
come to you guys or how did you get like
I was so excited when I heard that you
guys were on it and that you were a tag
team together I was like this is my like
improv teachers that like inspired me in
so many ways are now like part of this
like amazing product like how did this
happen the unbelievable I think about it
sometimes and it just feels like one of
those things we're both kind of like
nobody wants us in Hollywood no one
wants me in front of the camera like fly
to New York to take a job running a
podcast network yeah I was like fully
going into the producer and director
room both we were auditioning still
doing Apple sisters but we were like
okay money the moneymaker is our brains
they're like do you we got this
auditions like hey they want you to
audition together have you had that
before
not really no really yeah never never
and Jen Houston who knew the Apple
sisters from New York and is a amazing
casting director did orange if anybody
doesn't know and yeah she thought of us
for this part and they there was a
script Stacy and Dom it was a dating
tape up theirs and they said basically
it was like a two pages
yeah which included like then like they
I'm making a dating hi I'm Stacy I'm
done just like and then a singing
Jellicle cat sat and then then basically
the end of the sides it's something like
yeah whatever legal language they can
use yeah yeah yeah yeah etc yeah they're
like make it your own so we worked on it
we'd like we were like we're not gonna
just trust as long as we've been doing
improv we still now know that when it
says improv right your ship yeah yeah
and super careful yeah prepare like in a
real way it's on a live stage show
auditions only no live if we're saying
we're doing improv yeah yeah I mean
auditions and so for the audition we
like came up with a bunch of things and
came up with other characters we can do
and then just in case like we had no
idea and then she was like then the last
thing this yesterday so we did a bunch
of characters too but the last thing
that she did oh gosh right Jenny since
she's here she's okay we're gonna take a
quick break well jack apparently gets
his apartment
what inspected cool you're so PSS
fingers crossed
[Music]
to deep this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by Squarespace our buddy
yeah we love these guys I can't believe
that this is like my longest
relationship I've ever they make it
easier than ever for you to launch your
passion project whether it's starting a
new business showcasing your work
publishing content selling products or
more Squarespace is the tool for you
with beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website yourself and they have powerful
ecommerce functionality which lets you
sell anything online and analytics that
help you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever you can buy
domains super simply and you'll get any
help that you need
using Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support Squarespace empowers
millions of people from designers to
lawyers artists to gamers even
restaurants and gyms to turn great ideas
into something real and you can turn
your dream into a reality with
Squarespace and guess what guys you did
I have you have turned so many dreams
into a reality with Squarespace yeah I
mean you know I've made some websites
with Squarespace so I guess that's me
turning dreams into reality yeah this is
like a two-way relationship they need us
and we need them so no oh yeah please
please stick with us because I really
need this Web place and you guys can get
yours by going to squarespace.com slash
Grace for a free trial and when you are
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain at squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by our good buddies at ever Lane
that's right never overpay for quality
clothes with ever Lane ever Lane only
makes premium essentials using the
finest materials without traditional
markups and they tell you their real
cost because they want you to know what
you're paying for and why in fact they
are radically transparent about
everything from their materials to the
ethical factories that they work with
all of it and since every Lane sells
directly to you their prices are 30 to
50% lower than traditional retailers and
there
look better cost less and last longer
and they have the just really really
cool essentials so they got us to sign
up and we kind of picked a couple items
from the men's department and grace
picked a couple items from the women's
department I got these like really
stylish pants
whoo-hoo I also got a pretty cool denim
jacket I got a couple essentials I'm a
basic girl and they have all kinds of
basic wonderful pieces of clothing but
that are just you know better made all
the way around yeah yeah and they're
they're stylish they're not like you
know flashy no giant logos or anything
no frills just quality and right now you
guys can actually go check out our
personalized collection aka all the
items that we personally picked from the
website at everland comm slash grace and
you'll get free shipping on your first
order that's ever laying calm slash
grace ever Lancome slash grace okay
we're back from that awkward break but
turns out Jack has an apartment that is
approval of France the nice guy the
maintenance man turns out as a huge fan
okay okay sorry we interrupted this
whole audition process so they basically
you guys had you had to do this dating
tape you had to sing and then you
basically had free range to do whatever
you wanted yeah so we kept it within the
dating tape yeah we did some bits and
then we got a call back then she said so
you guys like can you guys are you guys
like physical we were like oh totally I
didn't have babies like a year ago or
anything
people were like ballet dance or
whatever and then I threw myself against
the wall Rebecca did the jump split like
RuPaul's Drag Race yeah yeah so of
course you're getting a callback
I mean I couldn't walk for a week then
yeah then we got a callback and we were
like this is hilarious what a funny
prank they're playing and it was like
you bring in a tag-team character and
they showed us or they had the link of
the original like rap from glow and
something like that so Kimmy and I were
like a one tag team character
no thanks we'll do five and so we came
in and it was like Liz Carly Genji Terra
and Jen euston so although with all the
producers dressing all women the day
mostly moms too which was so cool and we
were like we have three to five
characters for you continued and so
after we did three then they were like
keep going and we did and then they
talked just for like 20 minutes and
that's our story about like you know we
drove to Vegas all the time the two of
us had like we've started like three
businesses together yeah talk about our
kids and just kind of like over talk to
each other like how we do now like
really best friends that also did comedy
and we were like well I guess if they
want us like we've given them literally
like Rebecca like as a I had a podcast
but I ran around that room I did that
jump set I did everything and then I'm
serious when I said I couldn't walk for
a week but I I pretended that I was not
injured oh my god during the audition in
the callback and and then like two weeks
later we started wrestling and I also
tried to pretend I wasn't weak so where
we've is when you got the call that you
booked it completely were you together
I was coffee with Molly Prather and and
do you know her she's yeah we live
together in New York she's a comedian
yeah but we were having coffee and I did
this thing where I was like I can't like
I'm just gonna put away my phone and
turn it off as I need to I haven't seen
you in like three years you know so are
my manager our manager calls us and she
calls me like over and over again so
like I pick up the phone and she's like
I'm trying to get Kimmy and I can't get
Kimmy but I said I have to tell you
something and she was like like she is
really like hyper like so she's like you
got it you got it I'm like scream
like screaming all over the place and so
I texted Kimmy about 45 times going on
this would mean we didn't get don't get
excited don't get excited and then Molly
is just there and I was like like some
dude next door migos Oh would you just
go yeah my girlfriend's like we're gonna
scream play about glow and they got up
and left and I was like what a random
weird and then that night she came over
and we partied and we yeah it was it's
just so exciting and so unbelievable
like had we not gotten it I would been
like well you know I was right teaching
improv I feel like that so you know and
then so cliche but that's what they say
that's when things happen is when you
least expect them and when you're fully
checked out of something about to be
fully checked out of something and like
considering alternate like life journeys
to go on but okay so when you first
started tell me about like the training
cuz that's what I'm so curious about
because you guys are doing stunts you
are really and the stunt coordinator won
an Emmy so nice she was the first female
to win as a stunt coordinator that's
cool against her husband her husband
coordinator for Westworld and she won
well so in your face Ptolemy's Slocombe
it was us versus him yeah basically was
four weeks of training
okay I'm tribe oka roju nur is a
wrestling coach okay if you don't know
travel he's a wrestling legend okay
third generation wrestler has his
granduncle the original go girls how to
wrestle oh wow this is not a planned
thing it was just like somebody on the
show was a fan the knew his history and
I think I'm just kind of like it's just
amazing oh yeah that's really kids we
trained with him
and Shana and then Helena Barrett yeah
there's like two stunt women and you
could break down the moves for like
wrestlers who are carnies who are just
like just you know just to hate yourself
as hard as you possibly can and they're
like okay we're gonna have to keep these
girls like Ally so they would teach us
the move so that you know we can hit
slap fall bounce whatever fly without
getting hurt right in television
obviously you do 20 takes of something
screams because you have to do every
single angle and if you just do the
moves three times you know you're
talking a lot yeah wrestlers when
they're learning how to wrestle in some
ways it's like you you take as many
bumps as you can the first day and it
doesn't matter if your neck is stiff or
like one of the girls on the show Kia
she's a real wrestler and she said when
she first started pro wrestling she had
a sprained ankle and they were like well
you're either doing it now or you're not
and she said this is my chance so she
for three months was like injured you
know and so for us it's not the same
it's like we learned how to do it and we
can do it when they tried to do it
really slowly so that we didn't you know
have to have like insane injuries for
the whole format forward rolls like we
thought we were gonna be like doing
push-ups and sit-ups or word rolls and
then like you don't you kind of build up
to a back bump or you start just like
almost that's really falling on your
back right yeah that's the scariest
thing to me but when it's done Gary
it looks amazing it's like getting in a
minor car accident every time you do it
really yeah until you really learn how
and then I think maybe you get calluses
on your neck muscles I don't know your
core for sure yeah and I had no ABS
going into it so it was even harder when
just look you know just like mush so I'm
trying I'm doing as much Pilates as I
can before we get
muscles were just from like hangovers
from like throwing up yeah basically
what was the most intense thing to learn
or like the most intense scene at least
in season one well the most intense the
most intense moves I'd say the whole
thing in season one was like the KKK
match okay was the most intense you have
to bottom so for acting for wrestling
because we're wrestling with these not
only just like masse they're not like
lucha masks they're like KKK man but
it's also literally it was opposed a
bedsheet like yeah yeah cuz at one point
I got there was a smooth like a headlock
takeover or headlock takedown where
siddell headlocks me and takes me to the
ground and my like mass totally shifted
so luckily we had done it so many times
but you know we just did it without that
yeah one time she kind of got caught up
in my robe and so she landed right on my
chest and that was not gonna take that
was in rehearsal but I was like oh that
that's the that's painful that's my body
hurting that's a body honor that is fine
like after I was like oh that stings and
then you're good yeah yeah it seems
intense but it also seems super fun do
you guys get to improvise do you get to
like do you have to be so behold into a
script or do you get to like kind of be
loose with things in the ring they're
pretty good about letting everybody kind
of go wild oh really yeah great and
specifically our characters they kind of
let us improvise we pinch jokes all the
time like oh that's great because you
know our we know each other so well and
like it's hard to write dialogue where
people are overlapping talking so we
just kind of take what they wrote and
then we'll rewrite it so that you know
it's like what they want to accomplish
but it's so hard to write that kind of
yeah and make it seem so natural and you
can't write for the Squa brothers you
just kind of give them a script you're
like you do
squirt up yeah well and we did for the
beatdown biddies it was actually such an
amazing moment to see in
episode 3 when we finally get our
characters mm-hmm when were given the
beat some biddies and at the end it's
like the prompt we're doing our promos
and what I saw was like our jokes that
Kimmy and I had written like that's what
they put in and I started just crying
I'm like a golden girl like for mamas
family this and that because yeah this
is like everything you guys have worked
for and it's all coming together and a
moment that you've been like nothing's
gonna happen and it only took 20 years
yeah stick to it kids you can do
anything if you just wait 20 years and
get completely disparaged for the
industry that I mean do you have people
coming up to you now that you've been on
this show that recognize you as your
characters at all we were together we
were together people do and especially
because we like to travel on a pack all
the glow car also yeah it's that's so
empowering yeah when we hang out with
Britney young she gets recognized the
most sure so people will come up to her
and be like oh my god I love Carmen oh
yeah they're delightfully excited about
it fun like all the girls came out we
all come and support each other stuff so
they came out to see like my short film
at Holly short so like it was so fun
because even the way it was just like
Nash's concert like from the side and
that's so funny like seeing this concert
being in this little section with all of
us screaming at the top of our lungs
like it was it's just fun it's like
that's super fun well that kind of leads
into it I wanted to talk to you guys
about since you do travel impacts
Hollywood parties the you guys are going
yeah yeah those fun
thanks for all of us to go to normal
party yeah yeah I want to hear your
experiences with them because you guys
have been going to a ton of them
recently because it's like a ward season
and all of that and I love that you guys
seem to like you know kind of stick
together in that situation so how are
those events for you guys so you know
when I was a kid and I looked in a
magazine see people at parties and I was
like oh my god that's Hollywood and
that's what people make it opportunity
to go I was like I'm literally my best
life that I've ever lived let's do it if
I can dress up and let's go I don't care
I'm doing it like we kind of get
whatever most of the things we get
invited to in terms were like pump - go
- yeah and there's some of the girls
that are like oh I don't feel like I'm
in like I don't want to go and I'm like
oh party yes right now because it cost
$1,000 - and we were the only parents in
the cast and we will only shut down
every it's so fun it really feels like
this could be a fleeting moment or like
this opportunity and it's like even
though when I was there I would be like
oh look look at all those people I was
like wait no I'm part of this now we
went to the Entertainment Weekly party
under there before the Emmys and I just
could not comprehend like the pool and
like the glowing letters and stuff and I
was just like look at that show in that
show oh my god what's up this is us
watch the new black it's weird it's so
cool though it's like you're in a
television set yes but everybody still
feels kind of weird and awkward around
each other no matter what so the more
kind of WoW will reach that by like 60
is the epitome of just like I love
Hollywood
she would just come up to everybody be
like oh my god can we get a picture
well--that's have you guys what's your
biggest like fangirl moment at one of
those events if you've had one oh boy
this is an embarrassing one yeah I would
love to hear at that Entertainment
Weekly party you know all these huge
celebrities and normally the huge
celebrities I see them I'm like Sarah
Paulson clocked Angelina Jolie clock
RuPaul there we go yeah but I saw Wells
and I saw Wells and Sarah Hyland I saw
Kendall and grocery-store Joe I like
right up to Kendall and I said excuse me
I just want you to know I'm on Glo um so
I I love you from The Bachelor and I'm
so happy that you guys are hearing can I
can I take a picture with you and just
like you have vote for me I'm dancing
with the staff took a took a selfie that
I was like on my mom's group and they
were so bad that I would have would not
have had the courage to go up and ask I
constantly check in on their instagrams
to see if they're really still together
both of them yeah I feel like they're
just two ships passing the night but I
guess you know opposites attract marry
and love that's good good for you and
good for them I'm happy for them they
found each other know that those people
Jonathan Van Ness exposure that's
already made you know catwalk and put it
on his inside I wanted to ask you about
that I saw that I was like oh you had a
jvn encounter tell me everything like so
I did gave Thrones
yes season which I mean this is right
before he had just filmed queer I've I
hadn't come out yet god he's telling
he's like don't tell anybody but like
they put me in every scene because I'm
funny
[Laughter]
he's he is I don't know
pure light enjoy so funny I remember at
this other party like I for some reason
they kept thinking with a publicist the
party and then Jonathan came over gods
girl and all of a sudden he's like oh go
right in his golf carts and I was a tan
and Jonathan and I forget who else Bobby
and I was like this is gonna be us and
like Instagram photo I've ever Jonathan
at that Emmy party I mean they were just
like the kings of such a special
creature I don't know and I just
couldn't like it's so funny cuz like
he's got one of those hairdresser
memories so he'll remember everything
about you he was remembering that I had
to shave shave this out of my head for a
glow and I'm just already mourning her
being shaved
yeah his brain is unreal to me I started
listening to his podcast a little bit
and it's it's him authentically himself
but he's so smart and yeah well within
one sentence create some new piece of
like pop culture jargon and then also
give you exactly how the world works and
how it should work and you're just like
I can't even keep up with all the things
you're saying yeah he's um yeah I would
lose my mind if I saw him in person and
he gave her like a catwalk less or like
a walking lesson he's like I hate when
I'm wearing heels and I walk like I'm a
runner train track and so you showed us
what railroad tracks look like and then
he showed us how you're supposed to walk
in one line and then he like had Kimmy
do it and it was like oh you're totally
right like now I've never thought of it
that way and I mean I never had to fight
a catwalk type what does it take them
rope walk oh yeah Jonathan Van Ness
tutorial I'm walking in here in voice
yet looks like that's priceless
oh my god okay we're gonna take another
quick break and when we get back we have
a bunch of Internet questions for you
guys that I hope that you will do a ride
yeah but the world will be
[Music]
too deep if I seem a little out of it
that's because I didn't start my day
right because for many of us the day
doesn't really start until we get that
morning energy boost are you talking
about coffee you know I'm talking about
coffee now there's a new way to enjoy
your daily cup of joe thanks to cafe
monster oh listen to this it's available
in vanilla mocha and salted caramel cafe
monster is shaking up the ready to drink
coffee category with indulgent gourmet
coffee that's only a hundred and ninety
calories not to mention with a hundred
and fifty milligrams of caffeine from
coffee beans B vitamins and coffee fruit
extract cafe monster offers a simplified
energy blend that contains 1/3 less
sugar than the leading national brand
and in fact it's 100 fewer calories per
bottle than the competition but you'd
never know it by tasting it instead you
get all the same feel and flavor as your
local coffee house and you don't even
have to wait in line you don't have to
be around people that's right in fact I
think I'm going to have a mocha one
right now and try to wake up yeah
they're honestly dangerously delicious
the mocha tastes like chocolate milk
it's really really a crowd-pleaser yeah
you guys should really try it it is
delicious
and it gives you energy to really start
your day cafe monster
chill it down shake it up enjoy this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by burst oral care the burst
sonic toothbrush is the best oral care
you'll ever buy the burst sonic
toothbrush has a built-in two-minute
timer that is designed to make teeth
whiter and brighter in just days and
it's best known for its charcoal infused
super soft bristles the charcoal removes
surface stains and is antimicrobial
which helps keep the bristles hygienic
for the lifetime of the brush head and
it's proven to remove plaque and stains
without damaging and enamel of your gums
burst has the most powerful motor on the
market and the longest battery life with
up to four weeks use on just one hours
charge and they sent me one of their
toothbrushes I love it it's a little
like crazy matte black thing with black
bristles and then when I realize that
they were charcoal infused oh I'm a
scumbag strache and this is really up my
game it's a good a burst
oral care com2 get your burst sonic
toothbrush today and with the burst
subscription program you'll get a new
replacement head every three months for
just six bucks each and if you use my
code grace you're AC e at checkout
you'll also get 10% off your order
that's burst oral care comm with code
grace for 10% off don't miss out on the
special offer it's a great gift idea too
so go to first oral care calm and don't
forget the code grace okay internet
questions now but before we do I'm gonna
ask you the two questions asked every
guest that is on the podcast and the
first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at I
mean Donald Trump I mean obviously c'mon
yeah anyone in the administration
although my first thought was like Sarah
Palin cuz I was like you started this
yeah she started it's like the dumb
politician the beginning mm-hmm my TV
person I'm getting George Bush that
credit cuz yeah that person who's like
oh my god this is a reality show now
yeah yeah so we haven't had a Sarah
Palin answer yet I don't think no all
right that's no Palin spaghetti coming
up I don't know who was but like
whatever whatever senators whatever it
turned down like paid family leave or
paid sick leave like they can just get
so giddy all up in there shake yeah yeah
hopefully it's cold enough that they
catch some sort of cold bacterial
infection etc I can nothing home and
then they're like who's gonna take care
of mean they're like oh we should have
passed that long yeah we could take care
of me when they put all the medical
bills on their credit cards and then
they have to go bankrupt but it's still
not forgiven yeah okay the other
question is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or like a close call but
you can only use three words or three
small phrases no like for example mine
is college jogging front lawn all right
I guess mine would be Williams
burg North 8th Street specific front
door okay
athleisure flu West 49th Street - fun
New York memories how fun okay well as
long as you do it out of the store I
always in New York wish and there has to
be now I think we've talked about before
that there was an app for your phone
that told you where public restrooms
were all throughout the city because you
had to make a mental map in your brain I
started realizing that hotels are great
if you just walk in like you're you have
a room there and you can use the lobby
boundaries - oh that's a good one I
figured that out when I was babysitting
I was like nannying uh-huh and it would
be in New York so you'd have suddenly
the kid has to go to the bathroom you're
like yeah okay let's get into these
Internet questions someone to know is
Betty Gilpin real or just a figment of
our collective imaginations
Betty Gilpin is real Oh a real person
she's an incredible human being she
basically like spits poetry like I don't
know she's from another like dimension
and she knows more like she came back to
us and was like I have the knowledge the
wisdom I'm gonna say it in a really
funny dark way yeah I know I look like a
Barbie but my brain is like that of like
some like Black Plague poet you know
it's like she's she's really something
else and obviously like I had never been
me been made aware of her and took low
and the same yeah I and I looked up she
has like an extensive you know acting
resume which is nuts you know that she's
incredible her face is so fascinating
watch funny thing to me is that she said
one day to me she's like will you and I
were both clowns and it's like so funny
to me that I look at her and I see what
I think of as like a perfect physical
human right like the embodiment of
beauty like and just like everything I
just look at her and I'm like and I just
think it's hilarious Joe you and me are
like clowns with our faces Beauty is
just like an extra she's one of those
she's really inspiring people doesn't
really do social media all that much
Twitter me that she's just fulfilled in
her life
god bless what's that like and she
married a guy who I did a play with in
New York oh really
with Kent Roush he was my manager at the
time okay he put together this thing
about like like we put kids at a like a
scooby-doo s kind of thing okay and he
played one of the dudes and I played
like one of the high school girls or
whatever his name is Cosmo and and she's
like my husband cause I was like I'm not
gonna say anything I'm sure it's not the
same Cosmo Cosmo Kramer I mean that's
interesting I mean there's always so
many Venn diagrams happening in like
entertainment that's so cool but now
it's all come together someone also
wants to know if you had to choose would
you rather wear glow levels of hairspray
all year-round or below levels of
glitter glitter of course glitter house
we are huge split we talk
what's your end of day routine when you
have to get out of Boko harem a girl
like how long does it actually take you
it takes a while it takes like what I do
is the 25-minute quick treatment and
then just go home and sleep take it off
yeah I feel like it's like you know many
many cotton balls and I makeup remover
and over and over and over and over and
then like a hot towel and then you still
have to do more and more like stripping
there's a glue that's holding the
glitter plus the black mascara and the
black eyeliner and then we're new can
ozone it's even yeah I know that one
that seems like so intense yeah and it's
so funny because Wednesday I was like oh
what is this I makeup remover this is
amazing it was at work I mean my makeup
artist like yeah it's amazing cuz it's
Chanel and I'm responsible
someone to know your favorite wrestler
do you keep up at all or do you feel
like I need to keep up now that you're a
part of this franchise I keep up because
I enjoy it yeah and so I really like I
liked I a Valkyrie who is on lucha
underground and impact wrestling and her
husband Johnny mundo was actually salty
the sack Johnson on the original on the
first episode of glow so he was like our
trainer and so I actually broke the ring
he did physically break the ring off
camp really running back and it was
weight like a rope snapped or so like
the whole like yeah yeah completely
scrapped and he didn't call he was
running back if we do running the roads
running the ropes snap and he caught
himself this one six foot four muscle
but
like doing a hundred set up like Naomi
we met Naomi cows are amazing I'm so fun
Italian yeah they're funny and like
Charlotte Flair they are so what I every
time I go to a double w/e I come back
I'm like this is my new job now this is
my retirement job I'm going to get in
shape and I'm going to learn how to flip
and do this because Charlotte Flair is
just like a specimen I look like a
Pegasus that walks amongst us but I just
think she's so great and she's honest
too just like very athletically great at
wrestling no just like the acting side
of it just like the physicality I love
it
are there any like cameos coming up in
season three that you know about yeah I
know you haven't started filming yet as
far as we know where we're cameo yeah no
we know that I mean obviously the bus is
going to Vegas so there's gonna be
something to do with Vegas and they're
even like teasing on it on social media
like the what's like the production
designers been like showing his
inspiration and all the writers have
been like taking pictures in Vegas and
stuff are you shooting in Vegas we don't
know you don't know yeah I think all the
exteriors something obviously like we
are experts in Vegas yeah I was gonna
say I was like that feels like you guys
will right up your alley you know where
we go yeah just the Apple sisters have a
cameo someone oh yeah like you heard
before what's it like acting on be on
being on set with Marc Maron it's funny
because yeah he's awesome he's such a
good actor and so it's been like in this
show specifically it's like the scripts
feel like they were written for him
before he was a cast but I think it's
funny to see him get overwhelmed by 15
I've never seen so many bra and but
adjustments in my because literally
we're all wearing spandex and like to
sports pres are always too small because
they're straight up from the 80s I'm
like yes children's bikini tops
well that's who's gonna say the
wardrobes insane
it's very cool but also I will watch
some of the outfits and I'm like this I
couldn't do I think I'd have to like be
like I can't I have to quit now I can't
do it oh you do there are so many
conversations about bikini lines yeah
open I mean it's just like do you laser
do you wax are you shave it's just like
I don't want to ever talk about this
[ __ ] if it's the one like if you're
between waxes or whatever and then you
come in and is this like highways
graduation you're like so I have to tape
them so that means I always have to have
Spanish ladies clothes and 70s Bush a
lot of that but yeah he's also he tends
to his character Sam tends to monologue
a lot so he SAT himself being like I
feel like the first season like I would
just be like what was it like to meet
Obama what is it like to like every
podcast guest maybe I had listened to
his podcast for a long time years ago
saw him in a grocery store was like
that's Marc Maron and then now I'm like
in a show with him so now I'm just like
hey what's this like who's between that
and also like I just watched short
attention span theater if you remember
that and from Comedy Central and he was
the host of that I think you know said
stand up stand up at some point like I
like hip and like with his career for a
long time I used to watch him at Luna
lounge downtown and he'll be like oh
really
My Damn Channel and they sent me a my
friend Michelle to go interview him and
Sam cedar they were doing a show called
break room live oh yeah and it was just
the air America know something different
it's something that they were just like
in in a random like office space I they
weren't even like part of the rest of
the business I was occupying this office
space and they would just go live on
their lunch break in the break room of
this office space and just like talk
about whatever and so he wanted us Ross
wanted us to go like film them just
doing their thing and this is before he
was talking about starting a podcast at
that point he was so bitter about that
taemin industry and it was so fed up and
it was so in his head about like eating
and losing weight and all this stuff and
like it was I remember leaving so I
think I was like 22 or something and
being like that's the most neurotic man
I've ever experienced in my life two
years later he's the biggest podcaster
in the universe and I was like this is
nuts
then I'm industry is crazy but I think
he's great it seems like the part is
written just for him it was perfect for
him and like it was insane yeah all of
us have been together training for four
weeks yeah he was the one dude that we
didn't meet so we were like oh really
yeah we were like means we're we all
like each other like I hope he's not
like he's gonna change this year who
plays Keith bang like he plays a ref so
he came into the training a little bit
to to learn how to so we kind of like
met everybody yeah so when he had his
first speech were like someone's no
deeper for improvised sketches or
written sketches oh oh
well improvise well let's let's yeah
let's bring us to find the so a sketch
in general is typically written written
and you can also have improvised
elements to a sketch for instance the
Apple sisters I would put squarely in
that category sure we're heavily
scripted but we go off script to [ __ ]
around yeah and then we come back I mean
improv the great thing about improv that
used to do no [ __ ] prep you don't
have to worry about anything you just
show up in whatever clothes you're in
and then you can just like write a
magical unicorn and don't have to pay
like the great thing about sketches that
you can craft your performance you know
that mm-hm and you can also like rate
like you can fix jokes sure proof thing
so I mean I started an improv and
thought it was magical and I felt like
some of the most magical moments I've
had on stage are those like even in
Apple sister shows are those moments
where like something went wrong and we
improvise yeah so I think in general
like improv was always that thing where
I was like oh man if you could just
figure out a way to make money doing
this like long-form improv that would be
awesome and so yeah I think over the
course of my life I definitely have done
so much more improv and found like
amazing like moments from it but if it
sounds like you're kind of getting the
best of both worlds in glow
right now like you get to what it sounds
like go off-script and like [ __ ] around
with each other and make your characters
have that like very unique dynamic and
we never have to do a herald opening
okay so I want to know if you could
bring back a favorite TV show for
another season which would it be I know
what Rebecca's the bad you want you
maybe say yeah I think it would be the
Golden Girls Rebecca only I wrote a
Golden Girls fanfiction I wrote myself
on the one I would be yours that's a
great question I mean I really it was
sad when Parks and Rec went off the air
and I would like to have seen another
season just like it maybe be on that's a
what's a franchise that if it came back
that you would want to put yourself into
or movie whatever it might be I would
want to be Carla from Cheers
okay and I would want to be Debbie
Reynolds and singing in the rain
there you go okay last question before
we start to wrap up someone to know if
you could pick anyone in the world to
reenact the lift from dirty dancing with
who would you choose and would you be
the lifter or the lifti wait you said
repeat the first part of the question if
you could choose anyone in the world
okay to reenact the lift yeah I know
okay
Val from Dancing with the Stars and it
would be me being on Dancing with the
Stars and Val would be my partner and we
would do the whole number from dirty
dancing and I would be baby and Val
would be the other you know that got the
guy nothing matters except that I want
to win you know I really want to just
like get the trophy so vote for me
number two
all right I would just like to take me
and the Obama family but like they would
get vegetables afterwards you know
that's what the world needs I accept a
contract well thank you guys so much for
being here this is super fun we want to
give you the gift that we give everyone
from making time for us it's just a
fortune cookie for each of you I think
it's the same message in both you don't
have to because they've been steamed
open so they're not we found out we
found under clever new ways I'm a new
way okay okay the last person you pissed
you guys off hasn't had a proper [ __ ] in
months so please take solace in that
[Music]
okay good okay so where can people find
what you guys are working on now or they
can they see what's upcoming for you
guys if they don't know already sure you
can follow me at kami Gatewood on all
platforms on social media I have a short
film called control that is out
currently I think it's playing October
14th and 15th in Bushwick Telluride and
you just won an award for this right yes
we've won nine awards and 30 34
festivals now that's insane won best
film at Walla Walla Phoenix and a lost
Milwaukee my wife I'm not in this I just
know
you and I'll have I'm directing a series
called timeline which rebecca has cameo
as the Miss gallery of the history
teacher comes out April 2019 which I
used a lot of my experience writing that
fake encyclopedia that's the 1940s to
apply the history teacher thing well
truth be told she did an impression of
her dad and they're funny because the
best line was about oh yeah I was like I
feel like I'm at dentists cuz getting
answers from new kids is like pulling
teeth which my dad actually said when he
was my teacher in high school you could
find me on social media at hello Rebecca
and my name is spelled re Bek ka there's
no H only two K's she hasn't had to
explain this ordinarily but yeah you
could find out about my short film
consent which I made with Kimi and the
Apple sisters and global sister show
next week at scoops best oh yeah yeah so
we're you know just doing comedy
drinking in between I subscribe to that
religion thank you so much for being
here please check them out if you
haven't already and get ready for glow
season 3 it's so exciting
stay safe not too deep good bye - deep
deep deep deep this episode was brought
to you by cafe monster they are shaking
up the ready to drink coffee category
with indulgent gourmet coffee that's
only a hundred and ninety calories
available in vanilla mocha and salted
caramel with a hundred and fifty
milligrams of caffeine from coffee beans
B vitamins and coffee fruit extract in
every bottle cafe monster offers a
simplified energy blend that contains a
third less sugar than the leading
national brand but you still get all the
feel and flavor of your local coffee
house without having to go there in
person and they sent us some example
flavors and they got dang or so good
chocolate milk it's just like a sugar
rush without all the guilt so Cafe
monster chill it down shake it up enjoy
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jay
theory producer and editor melissa
demons writing by Diane King post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]